make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and yeah
let's begin what's going on guys this
is rob and on today's episode of the
ondo mega level we are going to discuss
what may possibly be the most powerful
version of the hulk that you've never
heard of
this is the blue hulk so this version of
the hulk first appeared in captain
universe the incredible hulk number one
written by jay faber and drawn by carlos
magno in 2005
not only is this his first appearance
but it's also his only appearance
so this is a very short-lived character
but one that is nonetheless immensely
powerful
and come on it's a blue hulk man so we
have to cover it
so this issue opens with bruce banner
alone in the wilderness with his foot
caught in a bear trap now the pain he
feels triggers his transformation into
the hulk who rips the bear trap off
and is immediately visited by a floating
blue orb that tells the hulk
it means him no harm but needs the
assistance of bruce banner now the hulk
initially refuses to allow banner to
retake control but the orb turns the
hulk blue
and manipulates his emotions to calm him
down and causes him to revert back to
banner and it's here
that we learn the orb is actually the
unipower now if you're not familiar with
the unipower
it is a seemingly limitless source of
cosmic power that bonds with those of
noble spirit in times of crisis
granting them nearly unlimited power and
basically transforms them into a cosmic
superhero
known as captain universe now the power
is bonded with several characters in the
marvel universe including bruce banner
who recognized the power as it had once
bonded with him to split him from the
hulk in an attempt to rid himself of
what he viewed as a curse
obviously it didn't work but banner is
excited to have another try now the
unipower informs
him that the reason for his visit is
different this time as the power itself
has been compromised and is in a
weakened state
and so the unit power seeks to bond with
the hulk and replicate his power
and also wants banner's assistance in
finding a scientist named dr gilbert
wiles earth's foremost expert
on the unipower to try and figure out
why it is weakening and so banner is
initially hesitant to help
because dr wiles is in manhattan and
he's afraid that if he turns into the
hulk he'll be a threat to all the people
there
and we learn the reason that he's in the
wilderness is to be far enough away from
civilization
that nobody will get hurt if he
transforms and so after receiving
assurance from the unipower that the
hulk ego
is being repressed banner goes to
manhattan and finds dr wiles now wanting
to conceal his true identity
banner introduces himself to dr wiles as
bruce barnes who's looking for
information about the unipower
shortly thereafter they're joined by dr
david garrett who says he's bankrolling
weil's research
in hopes that unlocking the secret of
the unipower will be beneficial for
mankind
suddenly garrett gets a call from agents
from advanced idea mechanics that are on
board a submarine that inform garrett
that the unit power
is currently inside banner meanwhile
wiles tells garrett that he was also
once the host of the unipower when a
plane he was on was hijacked and he was
able to use his powers to thwart the
hijackers and safely land the plane
then as swiftly as it arrived the power
left him and had been searching for more
knowledge of it ever since now garrett
then announces that he knows of the unit
power's presence within banner and fires
a beam at him that drives the unit power
from banner
hulk of course then takes over and is
immediately attacked by two robots that
were flanking garrett now once the aim
agents realize who they're dealing with
they opened up their entire arsenal to
fight the hulk
including weapons that had not yet been
tested and so hulk quickly gains the
upper hand but is soon
overpowered by the robots who hit him
with a beam of some energy that appears
to cause him great distress
however the unit power reappears and
merges with the hulk again
and once again turns him into the blue
version of the hulk now with the powers
of captain
universe hulk remarks now hulk is really
the strongest one there is suggesting
that his power level far surpasses
any power that he's ever encountered
hulk easily defeats the robots that were
attacking him and turns around to see
the body of david garrett with dr wiles
standing over him now hulk concludes
that wiles has killed garrett which he
thinks was the right thing to do
obviously but wiles informs him that it
was actually the bonding process between
the unipower and the hulk that produced
a flash of energy that killed garrick
and so as the police descend upon the
scene
hulk wants to stay and fight the banner
convinces him to leave which results in
wiles being arrested for garrett's
murder now later we see bruce banner
calling matt murdock from a pay phone
and that's where the issue ends and this
would actually go on to be a crossover
series where the unit power
is passed from hero to hero and so in
the next issue which reveals that matt
murdock has agreed to represent wiles
the unit power
bonds with daredevil and then of course
it goes on from there now maybe we'll
cover this story
if it's something that you guys are
interested in but for now we'll just
focus on the blue hole as i said earlier
this
is unfortunately all that we get to see
of the blue hulk the unit power leaves
him and as far as i know
never bonds with him again and the
really disappointing part of the hulk
having this power for such a short
period of time
is that we don't get to see him use the
power to his full potential not by a
long shot he just
beats up some robots and then leaves and
so it's sort of a dissatisfying
conclusion but even though we never get
to see it fully realized the potential
of the hulk being bonded with the inner
power
is immense and just to get a sense of
why i want to run through the abilities
that the unipower typically grants its
hosts
so typically anyone who possesses the
unipower has their appearance
changed to don a captain universe
uniform but this
change is not just aesthetic it actually
grants an extra layer of protection to
the user
by forming a protective layer of
molecules around them that protects them
from radiation
extreme temperatures or any number of
harmful substances
while the hulk does not don the
traditional uniform of captain universe
he does turn blue which means that his
layer of protection
is probably present for him as well
other hosts of the unit power have also
displayed a wide array of powers such as
flight telepathy and have been able to
manipulate energy time and even matter
in reality and so when we're talking
about the unipower it can turn
anyone it bonds to into an entity that
is well beyond omega level and that's
especially true with someone
that's already as powerful as the hulk
is granted the unit power was weakened
when it possessed the hulk but i still
think that we only saw the smallest
fraction of what the hulk was capable of
doing
with it and it's a shame that we didn't
see him keep it longer or go up against
a bigger threat during this short time
as the blue hulk but that's about it
guys like i said only a brief appearance
as a blue hulk and while we didn't
really get to see much out of him
knowing what we know about both the hulk
and the unit power
we know he would be capable of some
incredibly impressive feats
if he needed to i mean we're talking
about an incredible hulk that would have
virtually any superpower he needed
energy projection time travel reality
warping matter manipulation on a
universal scale
all kinds of crazy things right it
really would be a ridiculously opie hulk
and to give you guys perspective
this goes way beyond heart of the
monster hulk way beyond that way beyond
herald of galactus hulk
this this turns hulk into a cosmic
entity but with that being said guys
we're gonna bring this video to an end
let me know down in the comments section
what video you want me to do next right
because we're kind of running out of
characters to do and honestly
i kind of like the idea of mashing up
characters that we don't normally get to
see right like
if we had franklin richards who got the
infinity gauntlet or if we had iron man
who had the power of the beyonders or
like if wolverine became the specter
from dc comics right we gotta learn to
think out of the box guys we gotta learn
to think out of the box
and make up our own stuff but anyway
yeah guys uh we're gonna bring this
video to an end thank you guys for
watching
and i will catch you all later
peace
[Music]
hey
[Music]
ah
bye